as long as prosthesis have been around
people have been really focusing on
making it look like a hand and move like
a hand
but a hand is not just a grabber a hand
is a touch
it's touch that engages you with the
world is touch that engages you with
people
a prosthesis without touch is a tool by
giving touch
we're giving back a hand
[Music]
i worked in a factory setting before i
lost my arm
[Music]
i was doing some cleaning out from
underneath a shredder type machine
and grabbed material that was in my hand
and pulled my hand into the machine
i didn't think that i'd ever have the
sensation of touch or anything back
again
and then my prosthetist told me about
the research program up here in
cleveland they hope to be able to give
me the sense of touch
[Music]
the research that we've been doing is
reconnecting the man to the machine
basically learning how to take what the
prosthesis feels and translate so that
the person using it feels it
for the brain to
feel touch as being their actual hand
it's really important that we activate
or stimulate the wires that the brain
always used to get from the hand
what we do is we implant cuff electrodes
and then we apply really tiny amounts of
current that activate those wires and
that information then goes to the brain
so we've been learning how to place this
information on that nerve so the brain
thinks it's his hand
they can feel not just buzzing but also
a touch a pressure like somebody putting
a finger on their hand and in fact we've
been able to see that intensity of the
artificial stimulation
mimics
the intact hand
soft big blob
the first time they put sensation on and
everything it was just
incredible it was like wow i could
actually feel an area in my hand a
certain area
tingling and vibrations and stuff
small soft block
i said just
an incredible feeling
bringing a prosthetic home with a
sensory hand on it and being able to
feel and everything's changed life
considerably
it's just little things that people take
for granted
brushing teeth to be able to hold the
toothpaste and be able to squeeze and
tell how hard i'm squeezing it so i
don't squeeze it and go every place it
makes it a lot easier
we're at the point where subjects can
use their prosthesis at home they can
have sensation while they're at home
it makes them two-handed again it brings
back their hand and makes them whole
[Music]
you